what house we go under my name is perd
pass and welcome to I have some very
special news for you birthday just
kidding my life is completely empty but
if you have a lot of a lot of mail from
you bros out and I'm buying a lot I mean
like when I went into the mail office
the guy wanted to kill me little I
thought ah this is like the biggest box
I have never see it freshen huge this is
ha no more in the back but yeah we're
gonna open them and it's gonna be
awesome you're gonna love it it's super
heavy and kind of smells like you wah ha
ha hi there kids
hope you enjoyed all these Italian
candies anyway I just wanted to tell you
that you are always making me smile even
if it's a bad day
your videos happy new years roof is for
Menace Tommy I think if this continues I
will have diabetes by the end of the
month all right we got this beautiful
cow looking thing I don't know I don't
think beautiful and cow has ever been
used in the same sentence ever but all
right here we go what is this Merry
Christmas
it's been late and I just sent you this
smaller potterson for Christmas and I
should be very happy if you open it for
a Christmas episode [ __ ] epic brofist
from Poland I know I have a lot of brows
from Poland so rough Polish breakfast I
like to take my time opening my gifts I
like to keep a bit of tension go
he made like a Lego with me in it it's
like a tiny tiny PewDiePie
it was the fun everything it's also I'll
run thank you
next package I feel like it's Christmas
every week air with you bros I wonder
how long I will keep getting Christmas
presents mm they're peeled by you our
best Oh for me and my cousin wanted to
send you fan art and some Finnish candy
stay awesome thank you brother
I love candy
[ __ ] that song [ __ ] it ah that's a
beautiful it's awesome but the best part
it has their Blair net
[ __ ] yeah don't laugh I like this battle
it's beautiful I like a little beard I
might get a beer like that too all right
the best drawing ever he says this is it
doesn't get any better than that
and kanuk here is about what the [ __ ]
this is it's really big I could wear it
as a hat if I wanted to all right let me
see if I can do this
yay
it's a Slenderman painting he's gonna go
and come creeping now I think I'll just
wear it as a hat it's an awesome
Christmas card like it decorated it a
lot man sigh I've got flames in I am you
just really literally just changed
Santa Costas Lending Club nothing else
it sees you when you're sleeping now
that kind of fence I sling he knows when
you're awake you know the only bad a
good for we're good oh goodness
hey you better watch out you better
guard slender girls coming to town
I'm glad Santa Claus didn't visit me
during Christmas or ep I think the
curiosity has gone on for too long
enough about this diet dry package I
wouldn't be surprised
obviously I'm like scare that a dead
body's gonna be in here something
someone some fan wants to see me really
bad so he hides in this box
oh no I catch your eye open all right
okay they it smells like tea I'm glad I
didn't use poo on it thank you thank you
for that finally I'm done with your
package I started working on it last May
what but didn't manage to finish it
before school I hope everything is all
right and you still have fun and with
what you're doing it's so insane how the
bros have been growing and I
subscribe to you last year when you had
about 300,000 and now there's more than
3 million 4 million now yeah it is crazy
I agree
whatever I'm on creative in writing have
fun with your package greetings to mod
send your little dogs
Zaira breakfast huge breakfast alright
thank you Sarah for Jesus kite the
biggest package I probably will ever see
I'm still a little scared by this I'm
scared
ha ha ha ha ha at the shake yeah there's
more in here
what that [ __ ] ok it's a big way how do
you guard run I can't see anything but
the [ __ ] light go away I have a guy
how the gun guy's pissed just [ __ ]
killed himself
I mean IQ I'm so beautiful oh that is
awesome I love it you brought art o
creative how to meet up what are you
doing here it's from a afraid of
monsters you remember and it's awesome
yeah so cool
Thank You barrel for this Jeremy back
you gold hey but wait there's more funds
for my debt enough marshmallows for
another chubby bunny challenge be back
your muffin and anything at all we
remember every bad eye
Oh Japheth I'm another [ __ ] you know oh
I love it
so you open the first aid package and
what's inside sanity potion yeah hey let
me guess
light and a banana I don't know if I
want to drink this certain pot let's try
let's try some cyanide and out of them I
might just die right here it's like an
energy drink I'm so brave
this one says danger on it I'm a little
intimidated
hey that's so awesome
it's the is that gap I finally have my
own ESIC like that ass oh
oh it really doesn't taste good that's
awesome aisle I love it bro this is like
the most epic package ever but there's
actually more there's more I rejected
wear this because it's so awesome oh
yeah
surprise surprise sorry for the weird
cover open here it's like a it's like
board game with to the pine all right
hit it by the adventure first you choose
who you want to play with Stephano
I'll pick Zapata I'm spinning the wheel
alright it doesn't even there we go
alright I got number two as a star on it
I'm scared
chair mode sit still and how emotionally
for the whole next round if you like go
back to field number 170 write a short
text about yourself in three minutes
perform it as a wrap when the time is up
what that fukk how's it going brush I
guess all the house I want to post in
ways that will compose action for need
for me when I watch meetings on TV oh I
should not be a rapper okay just another
thing thank you Sarah for this package I
think was really amazing
of you to send so many cool stuff I will
be sure to send you back this ladder
requests don't worry you [ __ ] back
I got I have also got like 10 barrels at
least now there's a message inside dad
prepare the pie duck turned this is good
I'm not a duck I made you this barrel in
pottery class you can smash it or hide
orphans souls in it what I just want you
to know that me and my best bros Rebecca
and Ashley Ashley Anthony and Emily love
your videos whenever [ __ ] hits the fan I
watch your videos and just laugh my ass
off try not to scream brows too much
because it scares the [ __ ] out of us I
go play slender yo ass old duck look bro
what a beautiful letter so touching
thank you to zero or not to fail
I just think I store orphan Souls in it
type thank you
wearily low and low life remastered and
we both [ __ ] up school just to watch
you're awesome
don't [ __ ] up school because of me go
back a scull you go back to school now
I'm some the other fall oh yeah I'm so
pretty oh I forgot the Rings where are
the rings hi hi who are you calling gay
you gay I'm not gay you're gay
no you're gay yep nothing wrong with
being gay it's not called being gay it's
called being fabulous you know what I
think I keep this one there's one last
thing I want to do for your birthday
[ __ ] there was a lot of stuff I am so I
don't know if they may totally makes my
day to open these
just to see all the crazy stuff you bros
come up with famous sexy ass monsters
and the masks and all the crates and and
I'm going to finish this with a chubby
bunny chubby bunny challenge you who
don't know chopping ball a bunny you
basically put a marshmallow in your
mouth and you say chubby bunny for each
one and you see how many you can shove
in there it's also very common game
among prostitutes okay there I don't
think they're too old I don't even like
marshmallows
I read write in the comments how many
you think I can do copy one in copy
bunny
no problem sorry wanna call you on it
however here oh how we're on it I love
how Oh 13 14 if you can base 14 breaths
that's all for today bras thank you
again for everything you do just
whatever just watching my videos the
only that just makes me really really
happy I'm God I can keep doing this and
as long as you bros find happiness from
watching my videos i will be sure to
keep the winner um
as always i'm fries and goodbye wind
with the brofist but stupid with this
i'm sorry
feel like we're doing something else so
yeah thanks for your support bras now
stay awesome here comes your bro fish
pheromone activate
you